so after look at this guy together again
this is a very classic kind of question
finding a tangent or a normal using
product or quotient or chain rule in
this case I'm actually going to have to
use two so if you have a look at what
I've got here this is something times
something else yeah but this this second
something is itself it's something
complicated it's going to have to be
using the function of a function rule so
I'm gonna have to use two rules at once
here so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
start by labeling it's a product so I'll
call this guy you and this guy V doesn't
matter which one is which in this case
no because I could have just rearranged
it written a backwards it'll be the same
product okay so I can say from this that
f dash X is equal to V u dash Plus u V
dash or V dash you it's fine I just find
Wolfe easy to save in voodoo that sounds
funny anyway so I've got this now before
I launch into this I notice that I'm
gonna have to find the derivative of
this guy over here okay and this is a
bit of a complicated messy thing so one
of the things I've often done in the
past is I work that out first I work it
out to the side and then when I combine
everything I've already thought about
that so I don't have to keep so many
things in my head so I'm just going to
off over here if I say that this is V
then V Dash is equal to okay just forget
about the rest of the question just
think about that red stuff up there this
is the function of a function it's chain
rule so I need to do the inside and then
I do the outside or outside in whichever
you prefer what's the derivative of the
inside
that becomes one that becomes zero I'm
just gonna write down one okay I think
it's really helpful even though it
doesn't change the answer to write down
one because number one it helps you
remember I've done that number two
communicates to me as the marker you
know how to use chain rule okay you've
done the inside the outside is something
to the power of four so what do you do
when something is raised to the power 4
bring the four out the front
and then you reduce the power by one so
its cubed okay so now I know this is 4x
plus 1 cubed I'll stuff that in the back
of my mind and use it once I'm ready in
product rule ok which is now so V I just
have to write that as it is that
requires no change
oops that's a 4 no that's a bracket and
that's a 4
you - I can do that in my head you - in
this case is 3x squared + u is unchanged
and I already worked out V - that's kind
of nice so I've got 4x plus 1 cubed okay
now at this point here you have
differentiated that was that was the
hard part
but for two reasons I'm going to
encourage you to go a little bit further
the first reason is it's clearly quite
easy to simplify it in us and perform
the math that's quite messy ok um you've
got all these common factors in here
that you can take out secondly at the
moment you don't really know like you
don't have all that many things you can
do with the derivative like what you can
do is find a tangent or a normal but
later on it will become very important
to solve for when this is equal to zero
and that's much easier to do once you've
factorized so can you help me work out
what factors we can take out there's a
few different things I can pull out
there's an X plus 1 there's a number of
X plus ones that are in common there's 4
over here and 3 here so I can take out
at least 3 ok now just for the sake of
my brain I could factorize out more
stuff right now but I start to get
confused when I take too many things out
at once I can't remember what I've taken
out so I'm just going to do this step
first and if there's more I'll continue
what this leaves behind is X plus 1
times 3x squared is that ok over here
what gets left behind 4 X cubed good ok
but before I go on I notice oh okay I
can take out more stuff here right so
what would you like me to take out now x
squared can come out to
once I take out that x squared that's
going to leave me here with three X plus
three yeah three X plus three and it
leaves me here with plus four X and now
you can see why I mysteriously without
explaining why I expanded this because
I'm gonna collect like terms here so the
last line is this guy okay now some
people gonna ask me oh so how far do I
have to go I can't answer that question
because the short answer is it depends
what I can tell you is this is good
because you've differentiated this is
better because you're finished and
somewhere in here we'll say okay we're
done right this question is not
primarily about factorization is it
right factorization is a much lower
level skill than calculus in
differentiating so the the emphasis is
here but I think if that's all you wrote
down that's just lazy like you know if I
got an answer out of something and it
was four on eight and that's where you
left it it's right but really I do think
it is a fair bit of work though so if
you didn't get right to the end
if you factorize hours at least
something then I think that would be
worth something but it just depends if
you want to be safe you go as far as you
possibly can okay